[Music]
march 2020 marked the start of a new way
of living and although the virus took
away from us our communities kept on
giving we helped those shielding to get
medicine and food did all that we could
to brighten up their mood through the
darkest of times we didn't lose sight of
the amazing volunteers who played a key
role in the fight although we know the
battle is far from being won and our
road to recovery has only just begun
we're looking at how to ensure our
districts won't just survive but build
back even better and start to truly
thrive we've worked hard on our new
well-being plan which will help our
communities achieve all that they can as
we look to remove inequalities from
poverty and wealth and support our
residents with looking after their own
health we want to build on what we've
done well so far encouraging physical
activity and ditching the car doing all
we can to provide inclusive and
sustainable spaces offering lots of ways
for people to enjoy our fantastic places
making sure our district's children are
fit and fed giving grants to support
projects including the men's shed
helping new parents who need reassurance
and a chat although our work is far more
wider reaching than that we want weber
and mid-suffolk to be places people are
proud to call home but we realize we
cannot achieve this ambition on our own
which is why our strategy is a shared
dream one will successfully deliver by
working as a team for well-being is not
a fad or a buzzword and our strategy
gives the chance for our aspirations to
be heard focusing on well-being health
relationships what we do and where we
live building on our successes and
recognizing areas in which we still need
to give this new strategy details the
outcomes needed as we continue to strive
for our residents to lead active healthy
safe and independent lives it cements
our commitment to well-being being at
the heart of all we do a promise for
bright and healthy futures for our
residents
including you